it's very hard to keep and hold tears
when you're watching something like this
since the beginning of the full scale
Invasion
um we confirmed that over 150
um Ukrainian children
were deported unlawfully to Russia and
uh 308 children have been returned
recently using all our uh all kinds of
diplomacy and exchanges and it is
extremely significant that these
particular crimes of Putin and his
Ombudsman of human rights have been
documented and were a reason for the
warrant for the arrest not the total
Destruction that Russia creates in
Ukraine not the full list of war crimes
that they the Army have committed here
but the fact that they are unlawfully
taking children and it's not something
that you can hide it is something that
it has been proven this person Mariah
she was proud that she has adopted a
Ukrainian
teenager from mariopo and she was very
open about that and how she have taken
him she said well I just took him and
this is why all her claims that the
crimes cannot be proved they can be
proved particularly by her own words so
this is one of the most frustrating and
heartbreaking
aspects of the war the children who
cannot defend themselves protect
themselves are being taken against their
will to be raised as Russians and this
is something that my nation would not be
able to recover in Generations because
uh most of these kids they have their
life parents that are searching for them
they don't know what happened with them
and they have no access to to their kids
that are right now in Russia have new
names have new families and it will take
decades for us to restore the Justice in
this matter
Russia isn't denying that they're
transporting children into Russia but
they say they're doing this for the good
of the children they're offering them
Sanctuary from the horrors of War
well the country that have started the
war that have come to destroy us is
saying oh but we are saving the children
this is uh this is like does not come
into my mind does not add up at all uh
and
um we are doing everything possible from
our side to evocate children from the
war zones or potential War zones to keep
them saved however when Russia is
occupying particular City this is the
first thing that they are doing they are
taking children and uh and moving them
back to Russia this is one kind of the
crimes and war crimes and goes against
the rule of War however we know that
Russia does not go with any of the war
rules that
um that uh exist right now and
we do not have very high expectations on
that they will try to commit to them
I'm just getting a little bit of
breaking news I'm being told that Yen
stoltenberg of NATO has said that NATO
allies have agreed that Ukraine will
become a NATO member that's news just in
I understand that that's what he said so
what's your reaction to that oh there's
a this fantastic news it's a very high
hope of Ukrainian people the
um the ability to be a member of EU a
member of NATO is something that is
written in Ukrainian Constitution
however I will be very interested in
timing we understand that European
security uh is and the world Democratic
security is impossible without Ukraine
right now especially that we do have the
largest army that have an experience in
full-scale work in fighting however the
question is what would be the process
and when would this happen I have no
doubt Ukraine will join NATO but we need
for it to happen earlier rather than
later and we need to see a clear path to
that